En la pausa, varias personas me preguntaron
acerca de mis comentarios sobre el debate en torno al envejecimiento.
Y este será mi único comentario al respecto.
Y que es que, a mi entender
los optimistas viven mucho más que los pesimistas.
(Risas)
Lo que voy a contarles en mis dieciocho minutos es
cómo estamos a punto de pasar de la lectura del código genético
a las primeras etapas de comenzar
a escribir el código nosotros mismos.
Este mes se cumplen sólo 10 años
de la publicación de la primera secuencia de
un organismo libre vivo,
la del Haemophilus influenzae.
Ésta redujo un proyecto sobre el genoma
de trece años a cuatro meses.
Ahora podemos hacer este mismo proyecto sobre el genoma
en el orden de
entre dos y ocho horas.
Por lo tanto, en la última década, se han añadido un gran número de genomas:
la mayoría de patógenos humanos,
un par de plantas,
insectos varios y varios mamíferos,
genoma humano incluido.
La genómica en esta etapa de la reflexión
de hace un poco más de diez años
era que a finales de este año, podríamos tener
entre tres y cinco genomas secuenciados;
pues tenemos del orden de varios cientos.
Nos acaban de conceder una beca de la Fundación Gordon y Betty Moore
para secuenciar ciento treinta genomas este año
como un proyecto paralelo de organismos medioambientales.
Por lo tanto, la tasa de lectura del código genético ha cambiado.
Pero a medida que vemos lo que hay ahí fuera,
apenas hemos arañado la superficie
de lo que está disponible en este planeta.
La mayoría de las personas no se dan cuenta de ello porque son invisibles,
pero los microbios constituyen aproximadamente la mitad de la biomasa de la Tierra,
mientras que todos los animales sólo representan
alrededor de una milésima de toda la biomasa.
Y tal vez sea algo que la gente de Oxford no lo hace muy a menudo,
pero si alguna vez van al mar
y tragan un buche de agua de mar,
tengan presente que cada mililitro
tiene alrededor de un millón de bacterias
y del orden de diez millones de virus.
Menos de cinco mil especies microbianas
habían sido caracterizadas hasta hace 2 años,
así que decidimos hacer algo al respecto.
Y empezamos la expedición Sorcerer II,
en la que, al igual que con las grandes expediciones oceanográficas,
intentamos muestrear el océano cada 200 millas.
Empezamos en las Bermudas para nuestro proyecto de prueba.
Luego nos trasladamos a Halifax,
trabajando a lo largo de la Costa Este de los EE.UU.,
el Mar Caribe, el Canal de Panamá,
a través de las Galápagos, a continuación en el Pacífico
y ahora estamos en el proceso de trabajar
en el Océano Índico.
Es una tarea dura; lo estamos haciendo en un velero,
en parte para ayudar a entusiasmar a los jóvenes
para que se interesen por la ciencia.
Los experimentos son increíblemente sencillos.
Nos limitamos a coger agua de mar, la filtramos
y luego recogemos organismos de diferentes tamaños en distintos filtros.
Y luego llevamos su ADN a nuestro laboratorio de Rockville,
donde podemos secuenciar unos cien millones de letras
del código genético cada veinticuatro horas.
Y con ello,
hemos hecho algunos descubrimientos sorprendentes.
Por ejemplo, se pensaba que los pigmentos visuales
que hay en nuestros ojos sólo existían en uno o dos organismos
en el medio ambiente.
Y resulta que, casi todas las especies
de las capas superiores del océano
en las partes cálidas del mundo
tienen estos mismos fotorreceptores
y usan la luz solar como fuente de energía
y medio de comunicación.
De un sitio de muestreo, a partir de un barril de agua de mar,
descubrimos 1,3 millones de nuevos genes
y hasta 50.000 nuevas especies.
Ahora hemos ampliado este muestreo al aire
gracias a una donación de la Fundación Sloan.
Estamos midiendo la cantidad de virus y bacterias
que todos nosotros respiramos cada día,
sobre todo en aviones
o auditorios cerrados.
(Risas)
Filtramos a través de algunos aparatos sencillos
y recogemos del orden de mil millones de microbios en sólo un día
filtrando en la parte superior de un edificio de la ciudad de Nueva York.
Y estamos en el proceso de secuenciarlos todos
en la actualidad.
Sólo en lo que se refiere a la recogida de datos,
justo donde estamos a través de las Galápagos,
estamos descubriendo que casi cada 200 millas,
podemos encontrar una enorme diversidad
en las muestras oceánicas.
Parte de esta diversidad resulta lógica,
en términos de diferentes gradientes de temperatura.
Aquí tienen una fotografía de satélite
basada en las temperaturas --rojo significa caliente,
azul frío--
y nos encontramos que hay una enorme diferencia entre
las muestras de agua caliente y las muestras de agua fría,
en términos de abundancia de especies.
Otra cosa que nos sorprendió un poco
fue que estos fotorreceptores detectan diferentes longitudes de onda de la luz
y que podemos predecirlo según sus secuencias de aminoácidos.
Y éstas varían enormemente de una región a otra.
Tal vez no sea sorprendente
que en las profundidades del océano, donde todo es azul,
los fotorreceptores tienden a ver la luz azul.
Cuando hay una gran cantidad de clorofila en el entorno,
estos ven mucha luz verde.
Pero varían aún más,
posiblemente avanzado hacia el infrarrojos y el ultravioleta
en los extremos.
Sólo para tratar de obtener una evaluación
de lo que era nuestro repertorio de genes,
reunimos todos los datos
--incluidos todos los nuestros obtenidos hasta el momento en la expedición,
lo que representa más de la mitad de todos los datos de genes en el planeta--
y que totalizaron alrededor de 29 millones de genes.
Y tratamos de clasificar dichos genes en familias
para ver qué era los que estábamos descubriendo:
¿Estamos sólo descubriendo nuevos miembros de familias conocidas
o estamos descubriendo nuevas familias?
Y resulta que tenemos alrededor de cincuenta mil
grandes familias de genes,
pero cada nueva muestra que tomamos en el medio ambiente
añade de forma lineal a las nuevas familias.
Por lo tanto estamos en las primeras etapas del descubrimiento
de los genes básicos,
los componentes y la vida en este planeta.
Cuando nos fijamos en el llamado árbol evolutivo,
los humanos estamos en la esquina superior derecha con los animales.
De los aproximadamente 29 millones de genes,
sólo contamos con alrededor de 24.000 genes
en nuestro genoma.
Y si tomamos todos los animales juntos,
probablemente compartimos menos de 30.000
y, probablemente, tal vez unas doce mil
o más familias diferentes de genes.
Considero que estos genes ahora
no sólo son los componentes del diseño de la evolución.
Y pensamos desde una perspectiva centrada en los genes
–tal vez volviendo a las ideas de Richard Dawkins–
más que desde un punto de vista centrado en el genoma,
que son diferentes constructos de estos genes componentes.
El ADN sintético, la capacidad de sintetizar ADN,
ha cambiado a un ritmo aproximadamente similar
al de la secuenciación del ADN
en las dos últimas décadas
y se está haciendo muy rápido y muy barato.
Nuestro primer pensamiento acerca de la genómica sintética data de
cuando secuenciamos el segundo genoma allá por 1995,
y que fue el del Mycoplasma genitalium.
Y tenemos unas camisetas estupendas que dicen,
ya saben, «Yo 'corazón' mis genitalium».
Se trata en realidad de un simple microorganismo.
Pero tiene unos quinientos genes.
Haemophilus tenía mil ochocientos genes.
Y simplemente nos planteamos una pregunta:
si una especie necesita ochocientos y otra quinientos,
¿existe un conjunto menor de genes
que podrían incluir un sistema operativo mínimo?
Así que empecé a hacer mutagénesis de transposones.
Los transposones son sólo pequeños fragmentos de ADN
que se insertan al azar en el código genético.
Y, si se insertan en el medio de un gen, alteran su función.
Así que hicimos un mapa de todos los genes
que podían aceptar inserciones de transposones
y los llamamos «genes no esenciales».
Pero resulta que el entorno es fundamental para ello
y sólo se puede
definir un gen esencial o no esencial
sobre la base de lo que hay exactamente en el entorno.
También tratamos de adoptar un planteamiento intelectual más directo
con los genomas de trece organismos relacionados
e intentamos comparar la totalidad de ellos, para ver lo que tenían en común.
Y obtuvimos estos círculos que se traslapan. Y sólo encontramos 173 genes
comunes a los 13 organismos.
El conjunto se amplíaba un poco
si ignoramos un parásito intracelular;
y se amplió aún más
cuando examinamos conjuntos básicos
de 310 genes o así.
Por lo tanto, creemos que podemos expandir
o contraer genomas, dependiendo de su punto de vista aquí,
tal vez hasta 300 a 400 genes
del mínimo de 500.
La única forma de probar estas ideas
era construyendo un cromosoma artificial que contuviera estos genes en ellos,
y tuvimos que hacer esto en utilizando la técnica basada en casetes.
Y descubrimos que sintetizar con precisión grandes fragmentos de ADN
era muy difícil.
Jamón Smith y Clyde Hutchison, mis colegas en esto,
desarrollaron un método nuevo y emocionante
que nos permitió sintetizar un virus que contiene 5.000 pares de bases,
en un período de tan sólo dos semanas,
que era cien por cien exacto,
en términos de su secuencia y su biología.
Fue una experiencia muy emocionante –cuando cogimos el fragmento de ADN sintético,
lo inyectamos en bacterias y, de repente,
el ADN empezó a dirigir la producción de partículas virales
que dieron vuelta y posteriormente mataron las bacteria.
Éste no fue el primer virus sintético
–ya se había sintetizado un virus de la poliomielitis un año antes–
pero tenía sólo una diez milésima parte de actividad
y llevó tres años construirlo.
Esto es un dibujo de la estructura de Phi X-174.
Este es un caso en que el software ahora construye su propio hardware
y éstas son las nociones que tenemos sobre biología.
La gente se preocupa de inmediato por la guerra biológica
y recientemente declaré ante una comisión del Senado
y una comisión especial creada por el gobierno de los Estados Unidos
para estudiar este campo.
Y creo que es importante tener presente la realidad,
frente a lo que sucede en la imaginación de la gente.
Básicamente, cualquier virus que se ha secuenciado hasta hoy,
se puede construir este genoma.
Y la gente inmediatamente se asusta con la viruela o el Ébola,
aunque el ADN de este organismo no sea infeccioso.
Así que incluso si alguien sintetizara el genoma de la viruela,
el ADN en sí no causaría infecciones.
La preocupación real que tienen los departamentos de seguridad
es los virus de diseño.
Y hay sólo dos países, los Estados Unidos y la antigua Unión Soviética,
que hicieron grandes esfuerzos
por tratar de crear agentes de guerra biológica.
En caso de que de verdad se hayan interrumpido dichas investigaciones,
debería haber muy poca actividad
en el know-how para hacer virus de diseño en el futuro.
Creo que los organismos unicelulares serán posibles en un plazo de dos años.
Y posiblemente las células eucariotas,
las que nosotros tenemos,
serán posibles en plazo de una década.
Así que ahora estamos haciendo varias docenas de constructos diferentes,
porque podemos variar los casetes y los genes
que van en este cromosoma artificial.
La clave es ¿cómo poner todos los demás?
Empezamos con estos fragmentos
y, a continuación, tenemos un sistema de recombinación homóloga
que los vuelve a ensamblar en un cromosoma.
Esto se deriva de un organismo, Deinococcus radiodurans,
que puede soportar hasta tres millones de rads de radiación sin morir.
Vuelve a ensamblar su genoma después de la ráfaga de radiación
en unas 12 o 24 horas,
después de que sus cromosomas han explotado literalmente.
Este organismo es ubicuo en el planeta
y tal vez exista ahora
en el espacio sideral a causa de todos nuestros viajes allí.
Esto es un vaso de precipitados tras
recibir en torno a medio millón de rads de radiación.
El vidrio comenzó a arder y agrietarse,
mientras que los microbios acumulados en el fondo
están cada vez más felices.
Aquí tienen una imagen real de lo que sucede:
la parte superior muestra el genoma
tras recibir 1,7 millones de rads de radiación.
El cromosoma ha literalmente explotado.
Y aquí está el mismo ADN automáticamente reensamblado
24 horas más tarde.
Es realmente impresionante que estos organismos puedan conseguirlo
probablemente tenemos miles,
si no son decenas de miles de especies diferentes
en este planeta que pueden hacerlo.
Después de que se sinteticen estos genomas,
el primer paso consiste sólo en transplantarlos
a una célula sin genoma.
Así que creemos que las células sintéticas van a tener un enorme potencial,
no sólo para la comprensión de la base de la biología,
sino que esperemos que también para los problemas del medio ambiente y la sociedad.
Por ejemplo, del tercer organismo que secuenciamos,
Methanococcus jannaschii: vive a temperatura del punto de ebullición del agua,
su fuente de energía es el hidrógeno
y todo su carbono proviene de la captura de CO2 procedente del medio ambiente.
Así que sabemos de muchas rutas diferentes,
miles de organismos diferentes ahora
que viven del CO2
y que pueden volver a capturarlo.
Así que en vez de utilizar carbono procedente del petróleo
para los procesos de síntesis,
ahora tenemos la oportunidad de utilizar el carbono
y de volver a capturarlo de la atmósfera
para convertirlo en biopolímeros
u otros productos.
Tenemos un organismo que vive del monóxido de carbono
y que utilizamos como poder reductor
para dividir el agua y producir hidrógeno y oxígeno.
Además, hay numerosas rutas
que se pueden diseñar para metabolizar metano.
Y DuPont cuenta con un importante programa en colaboración con Statoil de Noruega
para capturar y convertir el metano
de los yacimientos de gas existente en productos útiles.
Dentro de poco, creo que va a haber un nuevo campo
llamado «genómica combinatoria»,
porque, con estas nuevas capacidades de síntesis,
estos vastos repertorios de matrices de genes
y la recombinación homóloga,
creemos que podremos diseñar un robot para fabricar
tal vez un millón de diferentes cromosomas al día.
Y, por tanto, como con toda la biología,
se puede seleccionar mediante el cribado,
ya sea cribando para la producción de hidrógeno
o de sustancias químicas, o simplemente por su viabilidad.
Entender el papel de estos genes
va a estar pronto a nuestro alcance.
Estamos tratando de modificar la fotosíntesis
para producir hidrógeno directamente a partir de la luz solar.
La fotosíntesis está modulada por el oxígeno
y tenemos una hidrogenasa insensible al oxígeno
que creemos que va a cambiar totalmente este proceso.
También estamos combinando celulasas,
las enzimas que descomponen los azúcares complejos en azúcares simples,
y la fermentación en la misma célula
para producir etanol.
La producción de medicamentos ya está en marcha
en los principales laboratorios
utilizando microbios.
La química de los compuestos existentes en el medio ambiente
es varios órdenes de magnitud más compleja
que la que pueden producir nuestros mejores químicos.
Creo que las especies de ingeniería del futuro
podrían ser la fuente de alimentos,
esperemos que una fuente de energía,
la recuperación del medio ambiente
y quizás
la sustitución de la industria petroquímica.
Permítanme concluir con los estudios éticos y políticos.
Retrasamos el comienzo de nuestros experimentos en 1999
hasta que concluimos un estudio de revisión bioética de año y medio
para saber si debíamos tratar de fabricar una especie artificial.
Todas las religiones importantes participaron en el proceso.
En realidad era un estudio muy extraño,
porque los diferentes líderes religiosos estaban usando sus escrituras sagradas como códigos legislativos
y no pudieron encontrar nada en ellas que prohibiera fabricar vida,
por lo tanto esto debe ser aceptable. La única preocupación final
eran los aspectos relativos a la guerra biológica
pero se nos dio luz verde para iniciar estos experimentos
para las razones por las que se estaban realizando.
Ahora la Fundación Sloan ha financiado
un estudio multiinstitucional sobre este tema
para establecer los riesgos y los beneficios para la sociedad
y las normas que los equipos de científicos, como el mío,
deberían estar aplicando en este ámbito
y estamos tratando establecer buenos ejemplos a medida que avanzamos.
Se trata de cuestiones complejas.
A excepción de la amenaza del bioterrorismo,
son cuestiones muy sencillas en términos de
si podemos diseñar cosas para producir energía limpia,
tal vez revolucionando
lo que los países en desarrollo pueden hacer
y facilitar a través de diversos procesos simples.
Muchas gracias.